[Musique]
étrangère
étrangère [
Musique] [Musique]
Musique]
l'année précédente
est en opération
[Musique]
ils ont vu quelque chose monter et descendre
des bosses ou quelque chose que les gens ont
vu ce genre de bosses monter
le de la surface du lac
et nous avons les enregistrements d'une sorte
de monstre vivant dans le lac,
le premier enregistrement date de 1345. il y a plusieurs
centaines d'années, le ver était
considéré comme très dangereux,
je pense qu'il y a une créature là-bas, il y a
quelque chose de vivant en bas  là-bas, j'ai toujours
un appareil photo dans ma voiture lorsque je voyage autour
du lac, si je voyais quelque chose,
je le décrirais comme quelque chose de
très énorme, il est de taille énorme,
je veux dire, tous les enfants de la région peuvent
vous raconter l'histoire du monstre.
le saumon est vraiment
vraiment
[Musique]
euh
horrible
tué
par poison ou viré des gens
luthement j'y crois je sais que ça existe
[Applaudissements]
résidus
[Musique]
ce lac est il est raide il descend à
au moins 110 mètres le glacier  Jock-le
et la période glaciaire, il a un
volume très très important, euh, parce que
la surface du lac, l'altitude de
la surface du lac est d'environ 20
mètres au-dessus du niveau de la mer,
mais le fond du lac est bien là où il
est le plus raide.  il a plus de 112 mètres de
profondeur,
nous avons donc
80 mètres sous le niveau de la mer du lac
et c'est plutôt inhabituel en
Islande, il n'est pas transparent
comme de nombreux lacs le sont
parce que ce sont des eaux de glacier,
donc je crois qu'il y a une écriture  là-bas
et au fond du lac, à
cause de la rivière glaciaire qui s'y jette,
nous avons une très épaisse couche d'
argile et de sédiments datant des
siècles que les rivières glaciaires y ont
déversés, sauf
exceptions
[Musique]
les gens qui m'ont raconté l'
histoire de où sont les gens en qui j'ai
beaucoup confiance, mon voisin Waltemash est très
déprimé envers la personne
et il travaillait avec plusieurs
autres hommes à mettre un
câble téléphonique dans le lac
et ils avaient beaucoup de  problème avec le
ver parce qu'il mord les câbles téléphoniques
étrangers étrangers
qu'ils pensaient que c'était impossible et
eux que les techniciens là-bas
ils n'avaient juste aucune explication à
part ça cette très bonne exploration
explication qu'il avait été en contact
avec le monstre  et l'escroc et le
monstre n'aimaient pas que ce câble
lui passe sur le dos
[Musique]
ou l'est de l'Islande comme nous l'appelons et
cette partie de l'Islande est réputée pour
son très beau temps, la plupart des Islandais  sachez qu'ils
veulent venir ici pour les
vacances d'été à cause du beau
temps,
nous sommes ici dans la vallée de
Floetstaluron sur la vallée de Floatstalar
et à travers elle coule cette rivière qui est
une rivière glaciaire venant de tout le chemin
du glacier Batner
et  donc cela coule ici dans la rivière
et les rivières qui coulent jusqu'au lac
Lardluth qui est en fait
une rivière jusqu'à l'océan mais euh
bien un lac fluvial
et bien nous avons les archives d'une sorte
de monstre vivant dans le lac le  le
premier enregistrement date de 1345.
il est donc assez ancien et est
mentionné dans toutes les
annales ou les Chroniques de l'Islande
à travers les siècles,
quelques observations chaque siècle, nous avons des
animaux très bien écrits à travers les
siècles et que vous pouvez lire sur
le ver qui a été vu à divers
endroits dans le lac et et
par qui et quand et comment
sa présence est
[Musique]
J'ai été surpris de voir tout ce qui a été
écrit à ce sujet, nous avons beaucoup de
descriptions d'anciennes paroisses en Islande
qui  parlez-nous aussi de la vie des
gens et de la nature et même là, vous
avez plusieurs fois des histoires sur le ver,
principalement bien, les gens essaient au moins de
le relier à ça, d'accord si le monstre
était vu ici au lac, j'adore, vous
pourriez vous attendre à quelque chose  très
terrible qui se produise dans la nature, des
éruptions, des
tremblements de terre ou un hiver très rigoureux qui
s'ensuit,
donc c'était cette croyance que cela ne se produisait
que lorsque quelque chose de terrible allait
se produire
[Musique]
nous avons une histoire sur l'origine de ce
monstre,
cette belle petite histoire sur  la
légende de la fille et de la bague en or ou la
légende du bel été est très
très ancienne et elle figure dans toutes les
collections de goût que vous avez en Islande
autrefois et elle était une petite fille
et sa mère lui a donné une petite
bague en or et elle l'a mise  l'or dans une boîte
et on lui a dit de mettre un petit ver
sous l'or et ensuite il grandirait alors
elle a mis le ver sur l'or en espérant que
l'or grandirait
mais l'or poussait juste le ver
c'était un ver géant et elle était  et elle
avait tellement peur qu'elle a jeté la boîte
dans la jambe
et puis le gâteau est devenu ce monstre
qui a attaqué les agriculteurs et a détruit
la récolte pour les agriculteurs, les
Islandais ont demandé à une clôture à une clôture de
venir nous aider
et de dire cela  ils ont rencontré ce gros monstre
près de la mer qui ressemblait à un gros
phoque,
puis ils ont rencontré ce gros patin avec,
je pense, neuf queues avec
des griffes empoisonnées
et une des choses, il a été blessé par
cette croix empoisonnée, alors il a dû s'arrêter
et  le nom de cet endroit est
finstarness, ce qui signifie là où le film s'est
arrêté, donc l'histoire vit dans les noms
des environs. Il est triste que les
ailerons Les magiciens du nord de la
Norvège qui sont venus ici en Laponie et
qu'ils réussissent après une lutte très dure
ils ont réussi à l'enchaîner
sur la tête et la queue,
donc pour cette raison, vous ne voyez que les
bosses qui montent
bien, il a été maintenu en vie parce que
les gens l'ont vu si souvent
au fil des siècles,
nous avons les mêmes descriptions
de la part de personnes qui  eh bien, je n'ai même pas lu
l'histoire,
rires
[Musique]
c'est en fait la première carte
de l'Islande qui
ressemble un peu à ce à quoi elle
ressemble vraiment avec tous les téléspectateurs et
les péninsules et euh donc il y a  à propos
du lac Lairfield, il est écrit une sorte
d'avertissement qui dit quelque chose comme
ceci: dans ce lac, il y a une
créature vivante, une grande créature qui se produit lorsque
des choses terribles vont se produire,
un monstre dangereux en fait, c'est écrit
en latin, donc  c'est écrit
là-bas
et cela a ensuite été copié sur d'autres
cartes de l'Islande pendant des siècles
[Musique]
Université [
Musique]
c'est en fait un panneau d'information mis
en ligne par l'association des associés du ver
et euh c'est euh ça explique
un peu l'histoire derrière  les
sous-vêtements, mais surtout cela
indique les endroits où quelque chose de particulier
a été vu et nous retirons juste
quelques endroits où nous avons les
descriptions de documents écrits des
annales des Chroniques de
certaines observations particulières, nous pouvons, nous
pouvons par exemple  prenez ceci, le triangle
avec la lettre D, c'est-à-dire
une observation de 1965, lorsque le personnel
ici travaillant dans la foresterie dans la
forêt de style Hadron, ils ont vu
le ver
ou du moins ils ont pensé avoir vu le
ver et ils sont en fait allés  jusqu'au
bout, ils l'ont vu là-bas et ils sont allés
jusqu'ici où nous nous trouvons
maintenant et là, ils ont littéralement disparu,
ils
nageaient, ils semblaient nager
en amont et ils montaient quelques bosses,
mais quand ils sont arrivés ici, à cet endroit  endroit
où il y a un très bon panorama
sur le lac ils l'ont disparu
étranger
[Musique]
Je pense que c'était en 1962 que mon père
regardait par la fenêtre
où il vivait et tout à coup il a vu
quelque chose monter du lac
et il a appelé mon  mon cousin qui était
là aussi et mes frères ont
vu quelque chose monter et descendre
des bosses ou quelque chose
bouger de haut en bas pendant 10 minutes et ils l'ont
tous trois regardé
très clairement par la fenêtre
et mon père est un scientifique,
il est très pragmatique, il était un  garde forestier
donc il était très clair pour lui que c'était
un ver qu'il avait vu
et il ne l'a
jamais nié qu'il a toujours été
convaincu qu'il avait vu le ver étranger
[Musique] [
Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
étranger
étrangère
[Musique]
étrangère [
Musique]
[Musique] [
oh ouais [
Musique] [
Musique]
c'est
True Blood
et le téléphone sonne et et c'est mon
oncle qui me dit que le ver à vêtements lion
essaie de nager jusqu'au rivage  et je me
dis que ce ne sont probablement
que des débris flottant dans la rivière
et je lui dis juste de les prendre en photo,
il veut que je l'aide à en prendre une vidéo,
c'est ainsi qu'il a pu
capturer une vidéo de
lachose
est
étranger
[Musique]
ils n'étaient pas très intéressés le premier
jour ils m'ont demandé de leur envoyer la vidéo
mais ils ne l'ont pas mise au
journal télévisé de sept heures le jour de la télévision ils
l'ont seulement mise sur le web
et quelques jours plus tard  le rédacteur en chef du
Web Roof Dot m'a appelé et
m'a dit que le Web était presque en panne
parce que des milliers de Japonais
regardaient la vidéo.
Nous avons alors réalisé que c'était peut-être
quelque chose de grave et nous avons ensuite fait un
reportage télévisé sur le site.  vidéo mais
la vidéo et le ver n'étaient pas l'
essentiel, l'essentiel était l'attention
que la vidéo avait reçue du Japon et
aussi des millions de personnes qui
l'avaient regardée sur YouTube.
Les trois premières actions ici dans la région
étaient ok, c'est ça  c'est quelque chose c'est
une position qu'ils ont plantée
là dans la rivière et qui ont fait
ressembler ça à un monstre ou quelque chose
comme ça
mais je savais bien sûr que c'est que ça
ne pouvait pas être le fait, je veux dire qu'il n'était
même pas capable  être prêt avec la
caméra, donc après que la vidéo soit devenue si célèbre, des
équipes de caméras en ligne et des salles de rédaction du
monde entier ont commencé à envoyer des gens en
Islande et
parfois il y avait presque foule ici de
journalistes et je
répondais constamment aux questions pour aider les gens à
diriger les gens qui  pour parler,
j'étais occupé à cause de ça et mon oncle
aussi était très heureux, tout à coup, il était
connu dans le monde entier et les agriculteurs des
environs étaient envieux et il était un
sujet de conversation oh ouais ouais
étranger
[Musique]
la légende du ver est,
je pense, plus vivante dans nos
pensées que peut-être les elfes et les trolls,
vous regardez les elfes et les trolls
plus comme un conte populaire,
peut-être que vous connaissez les Islandais, ils
croient aux elfes, ils croient  chez les trolls,
ils croient aux gens cachés et aux
choses cachées et certaines personnes le voient et je
crois qu'ils voient quelque chose
si c'est seulement dans leur tête ou s'ils
voient vraiment quelque chose, je ne peux pas le dire
mais
mon père a vu le ver et l'amour  beaucoup
et mon frère l'a vu
et mon voisin l'
a vu donc c'est un toi toi
tu ne le fais pas,
c'est difficile de nier la légende, l'
histoire quand quand les gens se tiennent devant toi
devant toi et te disent qu'ils l'
ont vu  le ver
[Musique]
étranger étranger
[Musique] [
Musique] [
Musique]
étranger
[Musique]
parce que je pense toujours à voir
quelque chose qui pourrait être lié à une
vie de vos observations, quelque chose comme
ça et parce que je suis  Je ne m'attends pas à
voir une créature vivante, même si certaines personnes
disent
que la créature se trouve quelque part entre
le monde réel et le monde spirituel.
Je ne crois pas qu'une créature réelle
existe,
mais je crois que beaucoup de gens
sentent ou ressentent quelque chose
qu'ils disent être.  une créature, je n'arrive pas à
y croire parce que
la créature a dû manger, tu dois la
bénir, elle aide à respirer et je ne pense pas que ce soit
un environnement pour les chrétiens de faire
ça dans ce lac, le
succès est comme une créature, elle a des enfants,
mais si c'est euh  quelque chose qui ressemble à un reptile
comme Nessie en Écosse.
Nessie est un peuple qui croit en Nessie et
croyait que c'était un plaisir pour les saurus, un
reptile, mais ils ont disparu il y a 60
millions d'années. Le
plus vieux rocher d'Islande n'a qu'environ
15 millions d'années et le lac est
jeune,
donc  il est difficile de
voir quel genre de créature
devrait vivre dans la jambe d'après les
observations
[Musique]
l'eau qui y coule est une
eau glaciaire donc il y a beaucoup de
sédiments flottants le lac descend à plus
de 100 mètres et les sédiments sont très
épais mais là, il fait 100 mètres d'épaisseur
et dans les sédiments que nous avons,
nous avons de la végétation qui vient du bois
sur les côtés du lac, dit le magasin Vegeta,
alors peut-être que nous avons un petit tremblement de terre
parce que ou quelque chose s'est passé et la
bulle monte et puis  ils ressemblent à
un sac à main sur l'eau,
je suppose qu'ils remontent parfois du
fond du lac
comme si du gaz pouvait jaillir
du fond du lac, donc on dirait que
quelque chose s'élève du lac, mais
en fait ce n'est que de l'air, des feuilles et
des débris.  si vous remontez en arrière, je pense qu'il y a quatre
ou cinq cents ans,
un public borné a
vu quelque chose d'étrange
dans ce lac, nous, le ver, n'est pas
la seule créature ici, il y a un gros
monstre scellé
là-bas et puis nous avons  un patiner le
poisson avec des queues et sur les queues, nous avons
une classe de position
et je pense que ce
n'est pas difficile d'imaginer que peut-être un
morse visite cet endroit
et des gens locaux
[Musique]
qui n'avaient jamais entendu parler des guerriers ou de
quelque chose avec  de grandes dents et ils le racontent
aux autres et ainsi de suite et ils se sont transformés en
monstre mais c'est aussi dans notre
subconscient je dirais parce que nous
avons tout aussi euh dans d'autres endroits où
vous avez des sortes d'histoires et
des choses mystérieuses vous avez
ces tapos  généralement,
une chose est que si vous allez voir quelqu'un
ici dans la région et que vous lui demandez, puis-je
avoir une truite du lac ou vous
obtiendrez probablement la réponse non non, la truite
de cet héritage de plus grand champ n'est pas
comestible, elle a tellement mauvais goût et donc  tu
ne veux pas ça
mais euh ce n'est pas le fait je veux dire la
truite du lac c'est la chair de la
truite est un peu plus claire à cause de
la couleur du lac mais c'est c'est pas
mauvais le poisson à manger et puis l'autre  le problème, c'est
que
pourquoi n'y a-t-il pas de bateaux sur le lac, vous n'avez
vu aucun bateau sur le lac, alors vous obtenez
l'explication, oh les vagues, les vagues
du lac, elles sont extrêmement fortes,
elles sont beaucoup plus nettes sur ce lac que sur
n'importe quel autre lac que vous pouvez  trouve
donc tu ne devrais pas sortir en bateau vers
ce lac
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Je pense qu'au Japon comme en Islande
il y a beaucoup de mythes
et
je crois que quand on a une
vidéo de monstre, il faut avoir un mythe  pour aller
avec, et voilà, cela s'est produit et
je pense que cela explique pourquoi cette vidéo
capturée par le conservateur a attiré autant d'
attention. L'attention internationale peut-être
en particulier du Japon parce qu'ils ont des
mythes similaires à un moment donné, l'équipe de télévision
est venue des États-Unis
et ils  j'ai fait toutes sortes de tests,
je pense que les tests effectués par l'American
Crew ne prouvent pas que la vidéo
que vous avez prise est fausse,
ils prouvent seulement que les débris flottant
dans la rivière peuvent ressembler à un monstre
nageant mais ce n'est pas le cas  dites-nous
quelque chose sur ce qui fait mal de
capturer sur son film
étranger
la vidéo que la fille a tournée
d'un phénomène ou de quelque chose qui
se passe sur le lac.
Je pense que c'est juste un temps
phénoménal, c'est un petit cyclope qui passe
au-dessus de l'eau, vous le voyez à l'intérieur des terres, où
il  il se déplace sur les terres
en prenant la cascade, donc je pense que nous pouvons
avoir une explication naturelle. Je
crois que nous avons deux types de
vers dans le lac. Il y a le vieux monstre géant vieux de six ou
sept cents ans
qui pourrait y vivre mais j'en doute.
et puis il y a l'organisme inconnu.
Je ne crois pas au monstre géant de 0700 ans
mais je ne veux pas exclure
qu'il puisse y avoir une
forme de vie inconnue vivant dans le limon au
fond du lac.
[Musique  ]
[Musique] les
jeunes enfants, ils y croient très clairement,
ils croient absolument que
le monde est vivant
et j'ai demandé à mon fils de huit ans
si tu crois au ver oui
absolument j'y crois je sais qu'il
existe et et  il m'a décrit à
quoi ça ressemblait, donc c'est très très
clair dans son esprit.
[La musique]
c'est important parce que ça fait partie de la
communauté et de notre histoire et
c'est lié à
l'imagination des enfants quand
ils font des arts ou  dessine quelque chose comme
ça, ils dessinent souvent le verbe et
ça les aide avec leur
imagination et ça sort de cette façon
et nous utilisons la Saga quand nous leur apprenons
l'histoire de la région des étoiles de la région
il y avait une petite fille et elle  maman
lui a donné une petite bague en or et puis elle a
ouvert la boîte et elle a eu
très peur
puis le ver a commencé à grandir
et il est devenu de plus en plus gros
ici ici il a jeté la boîte dans le lac
et maintenant
voilà pour la fin  de l'histoire,
je pense que c'est très important parce que quand
j'étais enfant, je suis né ici dans le
quartier,
nous croyions vraiment qu'il y avait des monstres
dans le lac
et nous nous en méfiions toujours et cela
faisait partie de la nature et
nous sommes très excitants.  j'essaie de le garder en vie parce que
bien sûr, c'est bien d'avoir un monstre
parce que c'est aujourd'hui qu'il ne mange
plus les gens
donc tu n'as pas besoin d'en avoir peur,
ce truc c'est Metro Play
et c'est euh
spécial pour moi parce que ma fille était
très  jeune elle était en deuxième classe
et elle a décidé de faire un
bras sans vie et je ne lui ai pas dit de
faire l'amour Luzon c'est
euh c'était sa décision décisive
[Musique]
ce n'est pas grave c'est ce n'est pas grave il y
a des arbres ici autour de nous
et  mais c'est aussi très grave, il y a une
montagne et il y a un lac et il y a
des maisons et
nous avons cet environnement et
nous avons aussi cette créature dans le
lac et ce n'est pas grave, c'est juste
une chose courante dans
notre vie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
choses
[Musique]
les touristes sont la
principale raison pour laquelle je pense que les Islandais
viennent visiter Phil Sierra, c'est que c'est
si vert que nous avons des arbres ici et
que dans la majeure partie de l'Islande, ils n'ont pas
autant d'arbres que nous ici,
les gens adorent  à visiter car c'est une
destination idéale pour les familles et
c'est un paysage magnifique
les gens voyagent dans la région ils savent
que le lac abrite les lyoflots
parce que c'est une histoire pour enfants très populaire
et probablement la plupart des Islandais
ont entendu  l'histoire à un
moment donné de leur vie et nous l'utilisons comme c'est
simple pour la municipalité
et cela nous dit à quel point il
est important pour nous
et vous avez également vu voir des œuvres d'art
plusieurs œuvres d'art à Elstern dans cette zone
qui sont formées comme un ver
le poème parle du plateau des champs de lions,
il est lié à husatanki là-bas où
vivait le poème,
donc c'était une chose très réelle pour lui ou ou
du moins il y pense beaucoup
et
ma fille a pris ce poème, en a fait une
mélodie et l'a jouée  un piano et ma
femme et ma
deuxième fille le chantent. Je l'ai joué dans
l'église d'Alistair l'année dernière, mais je
pense que c'est juste une indication que
tout le monde connaît le verbe "Tout le monde
regarde le lac quand il circule en voiture dans l'
espoir de voir quelque chose ou
je m'y attendais, donc le ver est bien
vivant aujourd'hui,
rit
[La musique]
est
associée
[Musique]
les touristes viennent en Islande principalement à
cause de la nature, c'est-à-dire que
les statistiques le disent et puis la
deuxième chose est la culture et le
patrimoine
mais  les gens ici, je pense qu'ils réalisent
que d'accord,
peut-être que les gens sont plus intéressés
par quelque chose comme notre monstre ver que
nous ne le pensions en fait
[La musique]
rencontrer les locaux est un produit ou un
programme que nous faisons plutôt que de voyager
avec la population locale  dans l'est de l'Islande
où nous aimons inviter les gens à venir en tant
qu'invités et leur dire au revoir en tant qu'amis
et nous invitons les gens dans des maisons locales
où ils peuvent dîner ou prendre un
café et
discuter avec la population locale de la
vie ici  la région
et notre tour autour du lac la vie autour
du lac monstre vous propose de voir
le monstre si vous avez de la chance ou pas
et de rencontrer la population locale et de leur demander
par vous-même comment c'est de vivre au bord du
lac
études
[  Musique]
l'existence possible
[Musique]
étrangère [Musique
]
[Musique]
les touristes qui visitent la région du lac
par notre intermédiaire viennent principalement du Royaume-Uni
et d'Amérique, mais nous avons aussi beaucoup de
gens d'Allemagne
et nous recevons de nombreuses demandes du
Canada  nous avons eu des disques du Mexique
Australie
étranger
[Musique]
Je pense que vous devriez toujours être conscient
qu'il peut y avoir quelque chose qui bouge
sous la surface du lac
et
très très occasionnellement, cela se produit au-
dessus de la surface,
donc  vous devriez toujours avoir votre appareil photo
à portée de main
[Musique]
étrangère